The protocol for chemotherapy says the day before chemo water fast but continue
supplements. Should I continue taking vitamin C, which is an antioxidant, greens
first and sun spectrum? Are there supplements that should be avoided around chemo
time? Some that don't interfere with the chemo's ability to work most
definitely. So the general rule with chemo therapy and understand this is not
really a rule. These are just suggestions because there's some natural
doctors that say forget it. You're not don't worry about not taking
antioxidants during chemo. I follow the idea that it makes sense not to take
strong antioxidants while you're doing chemo. No understand. If you take
antioxidants, let's say your chemo is okay so let's put a scenario. Let's say
your schedule is you have chemo at 9 a.m. on Tuesday. That's your chemo IV so that's
a chemo infusion at 9 a.m. on Tuesday. So should you stop taking antioxidants
on Monday? Well really your antioxidants are going to stay in your system.
Your vitamin C has a half-life in your system that's fairly short. That's a
water soluble vitamin. It's not going to stay in your system very long. We need the
extra vitamin C that you took can be a supplement. Antioxidants like alphalopeic
acid and stuff have a some of them have a longer half-life some have a shorter
half-life. Resveratrol has a very short half-life meaning that it's really out
of your system. So should you stop the taking any antioxidants the day before?
You can. It's all optional. So you could stop all antioxidants
24 hours before the chemo. In the chemo protocol I just say don't take it with
that 48-hour window. So in this case of this example that's why I wrote down
that example. You're not taking any antioxidants from two o'clock from night
o'clock Tuesday morning till not tell let's say you got done with it. Let's say
you finished the IV infusion. Let's say you finished at 11 o'clock. So then you'd wait till
you started it at night o'clock you finished it at 11 o'clock then you would wait till Thursday
which is 48-hour window that you would at when you finished at 11 o'clock
on Thursday that you would that these this is the window that you would stop
doing the antioxidants. You wouldn't do the coffee animals. You wouldn't do any really strong detox
things because you want the chemo to be in your system for that time. Could you start a day before
with that going off of all those? Yes, but remember what I said there's some natural doctors
that say forget it. You should be taking your antioxidants throughout that whole time that you're
doing chemo because it's really just protecting your healthy cells. It's not going to be protecting
your the cancer cells. So there's dispute in that. There are no
studies that's you know either way that the chemo was more effective when people stop
their antioxidant. There's never going to be a study because it's impossible to really
measure that. So it's just hypothetical based upon you know data that hey it does make sense
chemo therapies are strong oxidizing agent why be taking antioxidants during the chemo but again
the opposing view is the antioxidants are only protected your healthy cells and that's what will
help protect your healthy cells. It helps you from having you know help you to have less ill effects
of the chemo therapy. So that's step number one. Let's step number two and this question is okay
might I even see is this strong antioxidant alpha-lopiac acid is a strong antioxidant. There's a
number of other ones. There's certainly antioxidants and greens first but I would not say that taking
greens first is a strong antioxidant. This is like you need a good diet you don't stop eating a good
diet during the chemo. Sun spectrum has curcumin in it which technically has some antioxidant properties
but I wouldn't stop taking sun spectrum. I wouldn't classify this as an antioxidant. So really your
antioxidants would be your vitamin C your alpha-lopiac acid will have it always have some antioxidant
property but I still wouldn't I wouldn't even stop taking that. It's really those two biggies and then
part of the chemo protocol is also to stop any excess you could say liver detoxification
and that would really just be don't do and this is just within that 48 hour window right.
You're not doing coffee edibas. You're not doing castor oil packs over your liver. That's the
only thing that you're really stopping during that time. So that is really the chemo protocol
remember it's just a suggestive protocol there's people that think differently with that.
Your oncologist thinks the whole opposite side of the spectrum which should stop taking all your
supplements if you're going to do his care you know from ground zero and you never take any supplements
that's just absolutely ridiculous.